- Do you know how many
people care about how their
Instagram layout looks
when somebody lands on it
when only 1% of people
do that in the beginning
to begin with who are all
gonna cry that they didn't
put out more content
during this golden era?
♪ Eh. ♪
- You've got your perspective.
(engine revving)
(audience applause)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(easy R&B music)
Because you actually
have a business success,
like a real one, a real
tangible one, for that matter,
I think you really need to use
that as your shield to experiment.
Here's what I mean by that.
If you play it out, even for me,
and I'm like pretty far along in this,
all of it comes down to,
the lack of content, Tom,
comes down to judgment and insecurities.
It really does, right?
Like even I where I'm at
think about like, okay,
somebody's gonna go and see how good is my
engagement to my 4.1, you know?
Because I think all of
us go on that random
Instagram account that has
eight million followers
and you see they have 3,000
likes and like no comments,
and you're like, oh,
this person bought them.
What a loser, duh, duh,
duh, duh, duh, duh.
What I think what really
helped me, period,
is like no matter what
anybody says, like, oh,
you lost your way on Twitter,
you're not as good as this.
I always have like, but in the macro,
I've built actual businesses, right?
And I've had business success.
I think one way, I'm
just trying to give you
like a thing that might work for you,
like, who cares if a piece
of sawdust gets posted
on Instagram and it flops
and like somebody comes and
sees that it got 700 likes
instead of like 5,000,
which is what you should
get for that many followers.
You need to find a trigger in
your head to perfectionism,
or I want it to be good, is just not true.
It's a facade and makeup for
insecurity and vulnerabilities.
And so, you need to figure
out what trigger gets
you okay with giving
the team more autonomy
to put you on third-and-a-half base.
It's really, this is very meta.
I just said to DRock,
before this drive that we're
taking in wine country
working on this wine project,
hey man, we're makin' a huge mistake.
We have all this great video content
and if I really think back
to what made me good at
Wine Library and kinda
makes me good at social,
is weirdly, even though
I have no grammar skills,
though they've gotten a
little bit better over the
last 10 years, I'm a
really good copywriter.
Like I know what to say that will get
people to pay attention to it.
And I go, I feel the
reason that a lot of the
content that I'm being given
right now I'm not posting,
I've come to realize it's not the video,
it's the way you guys titled the meme.
So I said to him, it's like, look,
start sending me the raw videos,
I'll reply with the titles.
And I have a funny feeling
I'll be posting more.
And even as I'm telling you this,
I can feel the chemicals in my
body saying that's exactly right.
I think you need to let your team put you
on third-and-a-half base, right?
Give you the clip or
whatever the sawdust is,
and like, you know, like I said to John,
who's trouty right now, who's driving,
I have to go send an email
to ask somebody to make
a cameo in this wine promotion video,
and I don't wanna do it
'cause I hate asking.
It's unbelievable how
much I hate asking people
to do anything ever, anytime, in forever.
I hate it.
But having a Chris Rock cameo or whatever
the fuck in this will really help.
And so I have to do it.
And I literally said to
him, I'm takin' a flight
tomorrow from San Francisco, pound me,
like bug me until I do it.
I think you need to give
permission to your team of like,
like I think DRock and I
work well together because
I really, through the
last three or four years,
was like, look, even if I
snap and I'm like fuck you,
leave me alone, I'm dealing
with a fire at Vainer.
Or like, that's not important,
like that's not true,
and just keep pushing me
because that's what I need.
You have to create a framework
and trust with your team
of like when you're not
giving them the copy
or physically posting it
or whatever system that
you've created that you're the bottleneck
that they have the
ability and the triggers
to push you through until
it becomes second nature.
It's just so important.
Posting, here's the only
thing that's not debate,
like quality of a video of the
creative, that's debatable.
People debate if it's
good, if that was funny,
if that was thoughtful,
if that was a good post.
Quantity's not debatable.
Four posts a day is not debatable.
And it is an absolute requirement.
And here's the biggest thing, brother,
and I'm saying this for myself, too.
You and I are gonna be
really fuckin' sad when
Instagram's algorithm collapses
the way Facebook's did.
And it can happen any day.
And then we're all gonna look
at each other and be like,
motherfucker, when I
had the chance to post
four times a day and
get 30, 40, 50% organic,
and now I only get 2%,
I'm a fuckin' idiot.
(car driving sounds)
So that's it man, you know.
I highly recommend,
you're gonna get all these
cost savings of taking this internal,
I would pour that into
internal capes overwritten
in audio and video and just go, you know?
Just really push yourself.
Create that breakfast
thing or that framework.
Reach out cold to the
A list of the A list.
Obviously, you have a lot of friends,
so you'll have a lot of people who
can actually do it for you, too.
This guy knows that guy,
this gal knows that guy,
this guy knows that gal.
I guess the biggest thing
I'm saying, and again,
I'm really, I'm taking advantage
of this selling myself,
you gotta squeeze when that moment exists.
And I think that has
been driving me so much
in the last two years that this is such
a special time that will go away.
And then, while we're
waiting for voice apps
or augmented reality or whatever the fuck,
we're all gonna think back to these glory
days of 2014 to 2018 as
times where you could
have really built and we
didn't take advantage of it.
Just like email open rates at 90%.
Just like Facebook feed.
Just like unlimited
consumption on Twitter.
Dude, when I had 7,000
followers on Twitter,
all of 'em saw everything every time.
You're not gonna care about being precious
when you can't get distribution.
Right now everybody's being fancy.
Do you know how many
people care about how their
Instagram layout looks
when somebody lands on it
when only 1% of people
do that in the beginning
to begin with who are
all gonna cry that they
didn't put out more content
during this golden era?
- [Man] It was supposed to drag.
- So, that's kind of where
my energy is on that.
- [Man] (talking)
(easy R&B music)